una caricatura del poderoso presidente
de recep tayib erdogán en un sofá
presenciando una visión del profeta que
no agrada al mandatario turco es la
última portada del semanario charlie
hebdo que retrata si las tensiones entre
francia y turquía sobre la libertad de
expresión
este episodio ha generado malestar en
países de la órbita musulmana desde hace
días con turquía tomando la bandera de
esta consigna y haciendo un llamado a un
boicot hacia los productos galos aunque
es una nación con una constitución
circular y en el pasado defendía esta
identidad ante el mundo el presidente
hernán en la cúpula del poder desde hace
17 años ha tenido una gestión en la que
ha impulsado la educación religiosa y la
construcción de mezquitas
ellos literalmente quieren relanzar las
cruzadas las semillas del mal y el odio
han comenzado a caer en estas tierras y
es ahí cuando la paz es perturbada usted
y yo va que usurpó sus mientras tanto el
ejecutivo francés mantiene su defensa de
la libertad de expresión un mensaje que
ha acentuado desde el asesinato del
profesor samuel para ti decapitado del
16 de octubre por una
según la fiscalía quería castigar al
docente por mostrar una caricatura de
profeta mahoma en sus clases a pesar de
las intimidaciones francia nunca
renunciar a sus principios y sus valores
sobre todo a la libertad de expresión es
un ingrediente adicional para dos países
cuyas relaciones se vienen degradando
desde el año pasado de la mano de los
desencuentros sobre siria libia y el
mediterráneo